foreign
hey George camil here co-host of the
Ramsey Show and I'm back once again with
another episode of the best of the
Ramsay show don't call it a comeback
listen sometimes celebrities can get a
bad rap for their money habits but we
like to fight back against that
narrative that all rich people are evil
by highlighting inspiring stories about
rageous generosity from some of the
wealthiest celebrities check this out we
have decided that because the horrible
evil greedy rich people are everywhere
that James our producer decided we're
going to start exposing how horrible and
greedy and evil they are pretty regular
basis so Carissa Collins is the owner of
the popular Instagram account the
Collins kids which consists of her and
her nine children the social media
influencer revealed on Tuesday that this
guy with a 400 million dollar net worth
he's kind of a short guy
and um James no George Campbell no the
guy with the guy with the 400 million
dollar net worth that would not be James
and that would not be George Campbell oh
that's my bad yeah his name is Shaq she
might have heard of him Shaquille O'Neal
there we have heard of him yeah so he
took the Collins family out to dinner
Babe's Chicken
the next day he took him the
Mercedes-Benz dealer and bought them a
15 passenger van
after buying the car they'd went out to
dinner again at the Rainforest Cafe
where he dropped another thousand bucks
with the tip on the waitress just the
tip to the waitress alone
and after dinner he uh noticed her
Chris's husband's truck which was uh the
heat and air and the air conditioning
was falling apart you know it was a
dumpy truck and so he took him down the
Ford dealership and bought him a new
truck who is Shaq cause you know I could
I see like Elvis
I get choked up on these things man this
is amazing because like let's not blow
Pat that a thousand dollars for that
waitress at the Rainforest Cafe changed
her entire I mean that's huge yeah don't
drive past a 15 passenger Mercedes van
okay that's just a little different than
a thousand dollars too but oh my god oh
and I saw this one where you got up all
of this he dropped less than I don't
know what that van cost but he dropped
150 000 probably
and he made he has a 400 million dollar
net worth so that is like
you know it's a very very small
percentage ratio of his world he's not
broke from doing it uh I saw this when
the guy was in there and he was trying
to buy a wedding I mean engagement ring
for his wife and Shaq just happened to
be in the same jewelry store shopping
for something and the guy was kind of
getting nervous and he was trying to he
was paying and Shaq walked over and just
handed his car to the the person at the
counter and Pat him on the back and said
congratulations my man could you imagine
being able to just do that for somebody
just being in there to buy something for
your wife or your sister and all sudden
be able to
I mean come on man it was such an
amazing thing
you bought a house for this young man
who was paralyzed by a stray bullet
yeah these evil rich people need to stop
this that is ridiculous that's just
ridiculous that your your evilness needs
to stop that's right evilness that's a
word right
evil in action
goodness Shaq you're just you're
destroying the reputation of the evil
rich people come on man with that with
that outrageous generosity come on man
wow that's pretty cool I did not know he
had this uh knack for random
generosity like this that's very well
played but a thousand places he's so
subtle because he fills up the whole
room when he walks in it so it's no way
there's no way you can be Shaq and be
invisible but can I tell you he does it
I saw him I saw a clip of this with the
guy at the Zales and it was the most
quiet it wasn't a big hey look what I'm
doing he gently handed the guy and said
this one's on me and it's in his big
deep voice and he probably got on the
back and he said congratulations brother
and walked off and it was not a it was
I've been blessed so I can be a blessing
right it's that sense of I've been given
so much and I'm just going to bless
these families and and of course he's
got these big you know things that he
gives 500 kids to clothes here but but
it's just that kind of generosity man
that I can get choked up thinking about
it because it's so cool
um and thinking how cool would be on the
other end of this to be able to just do
that well the thing is with our you know
generous people make your eyes leak yeah
they just we all love them nobody hate
nobody hates generous people no but but
you know know you can't do that if
you're broke
if you're broke
and you're bitching about rich people on
your iPhone that you have payments on
you can't do that cause you're broke so
hello just just just a little heads up
there
you know bitching about rich people on
your 800 dollar iPhone thanks for
pulling the woman back on your iPhone
huge yeah James you just you just you're
just showing people how rich people
really are I'm
it's just
emotionally distressing to you know to
just let people see how people really
are out there because
generosity is all over the place so
George have you ever heard that rich
people are evil I hear it all the time
that the only way to get rich is to be
evil and steal
and be a crook
if you made money you did it off the you
know it you made it dirty you had to
because every everyone knows capitalists
are all evil
then you guys are getting the sarcasm I
hope out there but um I've been on
Twitter I know what happens over there
yeah oh why does anybody go on Twitter
anymore it's ridiculous but anyway the
uh uh
the truth however as we dig into it
millionaires
Deca millionaires 10 million or more and
billionaires uh have about the same
ratio of jerks among them as poor people
the percentage of people who are Crooks
is pretty much just the same percentage
of people who are Crooks and so what we
find is the vast majority of wealthy
people became wealthy by being good
people not by being bad people
so we decided we're going to have a
greedy rich people segment every so
often oh I like that we want to feature
some greedy rich people today we're
going to feature greedy Dolly Parton
everyone knows how greedy dolly is she's
a horrible person
at Dolly's theme park Dollywood she's
announced that they will begin paying
college tuition for all of their
employees
they'll want to go to school of course
they'll be covering 100 of college costs
if you work there which includes fees
and textbooks this amazing benefit will
be available to all employees on their
very first day of work it's available
for seasonal part-time and full-time
employees at Dollywood parks and Resort
Dolly you're just evil I can't believe
how evil you are Dave careful someone's
going to clip just that sentence out and
they're going to say Dave Ramsey hates
Dolly that's never happened to me George
just the latest wholesale wholesome
Improvement Dolly car partners made for
the lives of those around her the iconic
country music star has shown time and
time again that she's dedicated to her
community she gave millions of dollars
and raised millions of dollars for the
fires when the Gatlinburg fires happen
she has run a free book program for
children in the state of Tennessee for
decades uh that evil rich person Dolly
Parton We Salute You we love to hear it
that's incredible I don't know that I've
seen something at this level of evil at
this level this is a lot of evil we
should not be sending people to school
debt free like this we should not be
good to our employees wow because
corporations are never good to their
employees corporations are buying an
automatically evil just because you said
Corporation
that does have a connotation to it I
have a relative that goes it's the
corporations it's the corporations like
like it's some kind of thing I don't
know what that means I'm a corporation I
don't know what this means it feels
operations it's the corporation you
gotta have someone to blame for your
problems Dave and rich people are a
great problem great one to blame yeah
well it's easy to blame things until you
actually know people
you know one way you do away with sexism
racism
and um what do you call this wealthism
oh I like that is you actually get to
know those people that fall in those
categories and then voila it's very
difficult to hate them that's true it's
very difficult to think they are lesser
it's hard to hate generation lesser than
human if you if you really want to if
you really get to know someone of a
certain
whatever category demographic very
difficult to hate people of that
demographic after that if you really get
to know them because they have dreams
they have goals uh they have good
intentions and the narrative that
someone else wrote about them
is usually not true
well you know you only you see what you
want to see and that's what happens but
Dolly's had a great uh great PR for a
personal brand everyone loves Dolly no
one doesn't love dolly but she's greedy
rich people that's right
but look what money can do I mean it's
incredible it's awful it's horrible that
she's paying tuition for all of those
team members that's the most
unbelievable thing
what what a waste I might go uh just
work there part-time and on day one just
get some tuition go back to school
that's pretty incredible I haven't seen
anything of this scale this is pretty
cool we're a seasonal worker for joking
and sarcasm aside but I mean it's just
funny and of course dolly is a National
Treasure she's a treasurer for the state
of Tennessee uh we all love Dolly
everybody loves Dolly and uh not
everybody because not everybody loves
anybody in this world today I'm sure
there's some finding a way to hate on
even Dolly but um uh but oh my gosh do
you think this will be a trend what more
and more concrete rich people segments
it's definitely going to be a trip we're
definitely going to do this over and
over more of these greedy corporations
trying to send people to school debt
free you think that that we that there
might be a trend of us exposing the fact
that corporations are not all greedy
ding ding ding ah because corporations
are made up of people and not all people
are greedy and not all people are evil
not all people are Crooks just because
they have money you do facilities you're
offending a lot of people right now I
hope that's my goal if you believe that
stuff you're a doofus
oh it's unbelievable man well and here's
the problem the thing that we need to
the reason we need to have the gritty
rich people segment and expose the greed
of all these rich people and the
horrible things that they do in our
society like Dolly's doing this horrible
thing here we need to expose these
things because what Rabbi Lapin says in
his book thou shall prosper my buddy
Orthodox Jewish rabbi Daniel Lapin is
absolutely so cool we need to get Rabbi
back on the show it's been a while and
um but anyway he says one of the 10
reasons that the Jewish people
regardless of the time in history or the
location in geography regardless of
where they show up they have an
inordinate probability of Building
Wealth greater than the people around
them
and he lists 10 reasons that that
happens for Jewish people inside the
book thou shall prosper which is a great
book by the way I highly recommend that
book one of my faves of all times
one of the reasons is is that they
believe
that the making of money represents
service
and so they believe that the making of
money
is is a holy endeavor
work ship
is very much like worship
in that culture and so the idea that I
believe making money is a holy Endeavor
and
I believe it to be highly moral to make
money
if I'm in that culture now here's the
thing it is in in Psychology Dr John
deloney could expand on this but in
Psychology we talk about the idea that
cognitive dissonance when you have
something in your brain that does not
align a belief that does not align with
an action you cannot live in that in
that state very long you'll adjust
either the belief or the action
eventually
and so in other words if you believe
that making money and being wealthy is
evil it is very difficult for you to
make money and become wealthy
if you believe it's inherently moral
it's in line then there is no cognitive
dissonance and so you have this tendency
this magnetic pull so to speak to uh in
your psychology in your spirit to go
make money because you believe it to be
a moral Act
you know if you believe that uh smiling
is silly you won't smile but other
people believe that if you're happy you
ought to notify your face you know and
that kind of stuff right so it's this
consistency this lack of cognitive
dissonance but and so all you people
running around out there telling people
rich is evil you're spreading a disease
through our culture that keeps people
from wanting and believing that becoming
financially successful is good therefore
they can't do it
it's really a dangerous hope stealer
thing money's a tool it can do a lot of
good it can do a lot of bad you get to
choose I hope Steelers are everywhere
all over and so we're here with the
gritty rich people segment to expose the
greedy rich people
hey here's the thing if you provide
service
uh to one person you're going to make
one dollar or one amount of money if you
provide service to millions of people
you're gonna make millions of dollars
and you didn't steal any of it evil rich
people is a bunch of crap it's a lie
here's an example my friend Mark Cuban
and um
I can actually dial Mark's phone number
and he actually will answer we have very
short conversations because he and I are
just alike we don't talk on the phone
hey what see that's it yeah yeah done no
I email him sometimes and emails me back
no yep or maybe later we'll talk later
or something you know that kind of stuff
so big big deep in in-depth relationship
but uh um but he has uh to to his credit
billionaire this from uh this on NPR oh
God a billionaire investor and Dallas
Mavericks owner Mark Cuban has launched
an online pharmacy for generic drugs
that promises steep discounts over
traditional Distributors the Mark Cuban
Cost Plus Drug Company announced opening
its online pharmacy Wednesday the
pharmacy says it will bypass the health
care industry middlemen and help
consumers avoid High drug prices by
charging manufacturers prices
plus a flat 15 markup and pharmacist fee
all drugs are priced at Cost Plus
fifteen percent sign up and share your
thoughts and experiences with us Cuban
tweeted last week
Cubans Pharmacy says it will negotiate
drug prices directly with manufacturers
to lower its costs for consumers one
drug for diabetes patients sells for
three dollars and ninety cents for a
30-day Supply compared for retail at
twenty dollars a thirty count of um I
can't pronounce it which is used to
treat leukemia and other cancers goes
for as low as
17.10 at Cuban's Pharmacy compared to
two thousand five hundred dollars
instead of 17 at other pharmacies now
Cuban's going to make another billion
doing this
and he will have helped millions and
millions of people get drugs for 17
instead of twenty five hundred dollars
what's evil about this
it you literally have a billionaire here
that that by looking at this article
looks like he is attempting to provide a
public good somebody who says I've got
the money and resources I'm sick of
people I know who have lesser less less
economic uh buying power than I do not
being before they're I'm solving this
problem and I'm gonna make a lot of
money why why is that I don't understand
the opposing Force there yeah it's um if
I'm happy you can't be because you took
up because I took up all the happiness
yeah it's like there's a sums
yeah it's a fixed pie if you make a
bunch of money that means someone else
didn't that's not how money works oh man
Rabbi Lapin says money is more like
candles than cake if you get a big slice
of cake that means someone else gets a
smaller slice no it's not how money
works so it's more like candles when you
light a candle your candle is not
diminished and you light another candle
and you light another candle and you
light another candle and then you got
Christmas Eve service oh huh so this is
Mark Cubans here's a here's something
that just happened just a few minutes
ago
um I went and did a
talk with a guy who owns a couple of car
dealerships in Kentucky and I met with
this team around the tornado right he
was right on the tornado he asked me to
come up there talk about crisis talk
about stuff talk about trauma talk about
trauma and how do we move past this and
his first time his group got back
together and as a part of that
conversation I was asking in individual
people what are they what's what's
something that's real and tangible
that's going on in your life right now
somebody stood up and talked about a
problem with their home they don't have
a home yeah and they just bought a new
home and then a sale of their old home
fell through it was just a mess
and this owner quietly said he called
his wife and said I'm gonna buy a house
today
and I he didn't elaborate further ended
up buying that house and said I'm gonna
find something good to do with this
house and thought I'll Flip It Whatever
then somebody in this in when the
tornadoes came through
he was able to provide housing for a
family that's been displaced and now has
the idea of I'm going to keep this thing
and definitely I can just use this to
serve because people need a place to
stay whether it's two months five months
one year and now I've got an opportunity
to help him and that's a 30-year game of
somebody who's been stewarding their
money taking care of their people who's
got a heart of a servant and now has the
resources to say I'm going to help you
and I'm going to help them I'm going to
serve my community and no one will ever
know this happened because it's not he's
not a billionaire Mark Cuban he's just
owns a couple of car dealerships in a
small community that just got wiped out
by tornadoes and he's able to help right
he didn't have to call the government
doesn't have to call any sir he's able
to help and those stories go Untold day
after day minute by minute all across
this country man
so that the data actually says
that when you're
[ __ ] friend or family member says rich
people are evil the data actually says
that your friend or relative is a [ __ ]
but they're wrong that's what the data
says it says that guy's a [ __ ] he's
just thrown and he doesn't know what
he's talking about there's no firsthand
knowledge is no data to back this up
because the actual data says that there
are no more evil people among rich
people than there are among poor people
turns out there's jerks that have money
and there's jerks that don't and there's
good people that have money and good
people that don't and what we try to do
every so often on the show is we try to
feature a greedy rich person and the
horrible things that they are doing in
our culture today today we're going to
pick on the greedy rich person Elon Musk
Elon Musk says SpaceX starlink
satellites active over Ukraine after a
request from embattled countries leaders
he's made his satellite time
available to the ukrainians uh for free
yeah Putin knocked out their internet
and so he got a direct appeal from the
president of Ukraine he said sure hold
on one I'll move a satellite over there
something you can't do unless you're
Elon yeah I can't move a satellite over
there I can't either you can't move a
satellite over there but we're not
greedy rich people what's that joystick
look like by the way like somewhere at
SpaceX somebody's got essentially a
joystick or something or is it all
computer keyboard I don't know these are
questions I have Yahoo news reporting
veter Putin's unprovoked Invasion has
left parts of the country without
internet while SpaceX has launched
thousands of communication satellites to
bring Broadband to hard to reach areas
of the world we should bring the
internet to hard to reach areas of the
world because that's what greedy rich
people do because of course we know that
those hard to reach areas of the world
those people pay a lot and they're going
to make all their money back
no they don't have any money you dubes
okay so just in case you're wondering
but anyway uh users on the ground access
the Broadband signals beamed back to
Earth using a kit sold by SpaceX uh
whether you try to cut while you try to
colonize Mars Russia will try to occupy
the Ukraine
while your Rockets successfully land
from space Russian Rockets attack
Ukrainian civil people we ask you to
provide Ukraine with starlink Nations
stations to address sane Russians to
stand
a an official from Ukraine tweeted this
at Elon and Elon did he moved the
satellites into place entered making
them available to the ukrainians for
free and this just happens to be
obviously one of the richest people on
the planet a very well-known brand and
obviously an extraordinary current event
but what I know about a lot of rich
people is if the general public
especially all the snowflakes who want
the rich to pay their fair share if they
had a scintilla
of of evidence
look up scintilla that's a small number
it is it's a very small number
but if they had any clue how those rich
people give every day to do
extraordinary things for people uh they
they would they would shut their mouth
and sit down they just don't have any
you know why because good rich people
hate this with facts oh I know I'm not
using facts
I don't use actual numbers in research
that would be that's that's not the way
you argue things you're just supposed to
be emotional and go on Twitter
isn't it funny the irony is is those are
the people if you add up what people in
North America in the United States of
America private citizens give to
charitable causes and people in need
every year it dwarfs the entire economy
of most small Nations yeah
but we don't talk about that no because
rich people are evil and they should be
punished and they're not paying their
fair share that's right Senator Warren
is after Elon Musk because he didn't pay
the taxes she thought he should pay that
was a mistake because he apparently hits
back a little clap back there and wore
her butt out but um yeah it's true as we
say down in Tennessee she bit off more
than she could chew there so um that's a
problem but uh yeah just one more evil
person doing horrible things in the
world making uh free
free uh Broadband available to the
ukrainians by moving his own personal
satellite over their Nation to cause it
yeah he didn't send he didn't sit but
this morning I'm going to move a
satellite right that doesn't come these
are not conversations I'm in no he
didn't ship a bunch of food and clothes
he moved a satellite or two or three
it's extraordinary giving the country
internet apparently something the United
States of America government couldn't
figure out a way to do it oh of course
not no it's impossible because I'm sure
it begs the question Dave are you going
to go to space
yeah yeah dude I live in space
you're a little seriously this guy
SpaceX this is going to be he's gonna
let me go well it's not about let you
he'll he'll take your ticket yeah you're
gonna be able to pay for this in three
to five years it'll be you know I'm just
asking would you go if it's affordable
and you're looking I'm looking I'm
waiting on my credit card to frequent
flyer miles to build up
well then you're not going that's a good
one I like that that that would be rich
Dave Ramsey finally gets a credit card
so he could go to space
not gonna happen
oh I don't know Ken you strike me
somebody they would try that I just did
a I just did my first
um about 18 months ago did my first
parachute I know I had done this first
time I've done what was that like
skydiving we've actually not talked
about it last I was an absolute
adrenaline what was your Fear Factor on
a scale of one to ten I thought I was
gonna pee my pants that's what I I
figured I was gonna be that guy that
would be the least of my word I thought
I was going to be crying like whatever
right and you know what I just I I never
got nervous they did such a good job
prepping us right and the company was so
professional right uh and um and they've
got these cool things that they they
hooked to your parachute that if the guy
you're strapped to dies and his doesn't
come out once you reach a certain
altitude it automatically deploys your
shoot all right so I'm like this is
really completely idiot proof I mean now
we're using like four shoots involved
one of them's gonna go off I think I'm
gonna be okay so you went I probably had
more risk driving over there you know
jumping out of the airplane so I was not
by the time I got there I was excited
but I was not now were you did you have
the instructor yeah oh that's the only
way to do it front or behind rookies
with rookies they have to be in uh let's
see you're in front of them so you're
looking down yeah no obstruction we're
flying you're just looking at the Earth
very impressive that was a blast I'm
going again yeah Adrenaline Rush man I
got the bottom we went to eat breakfast
my hands are shaking not because I was
tired but the adrenaline dunk I could
only imagine it was so fun maybe I'll go
fly with me I think he's gonna go I
don't know right now I'm just concerned
about elon's generosity I I can't
believe he's an evil rich person of this
magnitude you can bless him out when
you're on the shuttle with it that's it
you know you evil rich people stop your
generosity you're giving evil rich
people everywhere A Bad Name
Mila is from Ukraine and uh These Guys
these gritty rich people they went and
raised over 34 million dollars to help
humanitarian Aid in the Ukraine
temporary housing for the refugees
according to the couple's GoFundMe page
Kunis was born in Ukraine in 1983 moved
to the United States when she was eight
years old she says ukrainians are proud
and brave people who deserve our help in
their time of need and so these greedy
rich people she and Ashton they got
together with some other greedy rich
people and made a bunch of donations the
nerve I can't believe they helped people
with their money that's awful they're
giving a bad name to the greedy rich
people
so uh Mila and Ashton created the
fundraising page March March 3rd made a
personal donation see here they here
they they and then they told people they
did it so they're just awful they
they're three million dollars they put
in their own money
then more than 65 000 donors have
contributed to the campaign the list of
top contributors include some of the
world's greediest wealthiest individuals
billionaire Larry Ellison the chairman
of Oracle uh he donated five million
because he's a pretty rich guy uh
Silicon Valley private Equity Firm DST
Global greedy rich people they
contributed three million dollars and
the Family Foundation of DST partner
Yuri Milner gave another two and a half
million dollars uh so that's like damn
that's like five and a half million
dollars from the DST group alone but
they're all gritty rich people we know
about that another two and a half
million dollar donation came from the
family of renowned Silicon Valley angel
investor Ron Conway fashion model uh
Carl is it Carly Kloss I think it's
close close I think you well I'm not
that happy I'm I'm one degree hipper
she's a fashion model which is two
things I don't know anything about
fashion or models so uh Josh Josh
Kushner uh donated 250 thousand dollars
through his foundation he's a venture
capitalist another one of those greedy
rich people and so uh we're overwhelmed
with gratitude for this support from the
greedy rich people said Ashton Kutcher
you can say the last part I added it and
in an Instagram post on March 17th our
Collective greedy rich people effort
will provide a softer Landing for many
people as they Forge ahead to their
future of uncertainty humanitarian Aid
temporary housing for Ukrainian refugees
brought to you by greedy rich people wow
and I'm on the site now I'm looking at
the GoFundMe they're up to over 36
million dollars with over almost 76 000
donations be precisely more than 36
million 36 million dollars more than the
US government has given oh yeah to help
Ukrainian refugees but the gritty rich
people they're doing something about
disgusting and inspiring the broke
people send money
you know I it doesn't say is there a
broke People page I don't think that's
on here but I guess broke you know if
there's a broken people GoFundMe donate
page yeah you can donate as little
because you can put the change out of
every dollar that you don't use and so
you could send a nickel or seven cents
or you know that kind of stuff and I'm
sure it'll change their life
but the greedy rich people dropped in 36
million so um they went first just
wanted you to know that those people are
out there and they're horrible and
you know we don't we don't we don't
endorse that kind of generosity because
it gives greedy rich people a bad name
we're here to make them look good not
bad do you recognize the sarcasm font in
my voice I hope so although some people
listening may not understand it well
hang around you'll get it after a while
James our producer came up with the idea
that we needed to do a greedy rich
people segment and periodically expose
these greedy horrible rich people
segments today we're going to pick on a
superstar yes in the NBA yeah uh
bismack biyombo yeah and I'm not an NBA
guy obviously because I hesitated
pronouncing that don't tell me Dave
Ramsey doesn't prepare let's you should
just know that you should just know that
I spent yeah right so
bismack uh apparently is one of these
gritty rich people because according to
this article on CNN uh he donated his
entire salary from the NBA
to build a hospital in his native
Democratic Republic of the Congo in
Africa and honor his late father the
Phoenix Suns star the 29 year old
returned to the NBA in January signing a
contract for the duration of the season
and he donated the entire amount 1.3
million dollars to build a hospital in
his home country and he uh he donned the
18 jersey for the sons and honor of his
father's June 18th birthday his father
passed away and he's donating the entire
amount to be named after Francis would
consolidate his legacy whilst helping
those in need back home I told my agent
my salary for this year will be going to
the construction of a hospital back home
to give hope to the Hopeless at home and
those individuals that cannot take their
family members out biambo said greedy
rich guy yeah oh by the way Dave that
1.3 million dollar donation of a salad
for the hospital is in addition to the
almost million dollars worth of medical
equipment that his foundation sent over
to the Democratic Republic of Congo in
the earliest of 2020 that's what pretty
rich people do they usually double dip
so yeah so if you're going to be greedy
and Rich you should do it we have a
pattern of their greed yeah this is
clearly a pattern out of control
generosity by these greedy rich people
it needs to stop you're giving bad name
to the greedy rich people when you're
generous like this it you need to stop
yeah now here's what I'll also say about
how can that fit with the narrative
that's out there
well because here's I mean well it can't
he's messing it up he can't he's messing
up the narrative but this is the rare
situation Dave you know this
um I'm not very wealthy at all but I do
know a lot of wealthy people and here's
what I know they don't normally talk
about their charity and their donation
this is a story because he's in the NBA
but most rich people you don't even know
how much they're giving you don't even
know where their fingerprints are
because it turns out these awful greedy
rich people don't need credit either
oh they weren't doing they weren't
taking a poll it wasn't Optics yeah no
they just do it oh kind of like covid
yeah yeah it wasn't about Optics it
wasn't about the way it looked it's the
way it actually is yeah oh that
I can't tell you how many rich people
that I've heard of and known that that
paid for supplies and private planes and
different countries all around the world
you never even see it on CNN but it's
happening it won't you you won't because
you won't find out about it and it
doesn't be reported I'm glad he reported
this because it exposed the greedy rich
people for what they really are yes and
I'm glad we have a news story I'm glad
CNN did their investigative journalism
and discovered that this guy is yet
another of those horrible successful
people who are the best at their craft
in the world and I chose to give the
money away and build a hospital I think
it's just horrible it's just awful I
can't believe people really do stuff
like that yeah this new generation and
worse than that yeah he even talked
about it yeah and inspired other people
to be greedy rich people yeah it's just
horrible I can't believe if you like
this episode click here for the next one
featuring calls all about buying and
selling a home in this crazy real estate
market